so I woke up this morning I had planned
my morning and we really planned the
entire production day around watching as
much of the Robert Muller testimony
before Congress as possible so that we
could talk about it today which I'm
going to do right now rather than on
tomorrow's show and I thought as I got
on my computer at 8:25 a.m. this morning
to pull up the stream I should see if
Donald Trump has been tweeting because
he's been panicking for days yesterday
we covered Donald Trump saying that
Robert mola shouldn't even be allowed to
testify I should look at whether Donald
Trump has sent any tweets I pull up
Donald Trump's Twitter account and he
sent ten tweets in the hours and even
minutes before Robert Mulder's testimony
starting last night winding up even more
this morning this is a guy who's
panicked this is the president it's
important not to lose our sense of scope
this is the president devolving into a
childish nincompoop and I use the term
nincompoop by its dictionary definition
not as an ad hominem because of
congressional testimony by a former
special prosecutor and you know what
unfortunately in a sense fortunately for
Trump Mueller's testimony at least the
first several hours that have taken
place as of right now have not been
particularly damaging to Donald Trump
but we'll get to that let's look at
Donald Trump's tweets to begin with
starting last night quote so Robert
Muller has now asked for his longtime
never Trump or lawyer to sit beside him
and help with answers what's this all
about his lawyer represented the
basement server guy who got off free in
the crooked Hillary case this should not
be allowed rigged witch-hunt continuing
so democrats and others can illegally
fabricate a crime try pinning it on a
very innocent president and when he
fights back against this illegal and
treasonous attack on our country they
call it obstruction wrong why didn't
robert muller investigate the
investigators continuing quote it was
never agreed that robert muller could
use one of his many democrat never trump
or lawyers to sit next to him and help
him with his answers this was
specifically not a
- and I would never have agreed to it of
course it's not up to Trump the greatest
witch hunt in US history by far
why didn't Robert Moeller and his band
of 18 angry Democrats spent any time
investigating crooked Hillary Clinton
lying in leakin james comey lisa page
and her psycho lover Peter s Andy McCabe
the beautiful or family fusion GPS and
how many more and many more including
himself and Andrew W this is the
president tweeting ok continuing so why
didn't the hide why didn't the highly
conflicted robert muller investigate how
and why crooked Hillary Clinton deleted
and acid-washed 33,000 emails
immediately after getting a subpoena
from the United States Congress
she must have great lawyers no collusion
no obstruction Keep America great
continuing this is still Trump on
Twitter this morning it has been
reported that Robert Moeller is saying
that he did not apply an interview for
the job of FBI director and get turned
down the day before he was wrongfully
appointed special counsel good luck even
following this stuff hope he doesn't say
that under oath in that we have numerous
witnesses to the interview including the
Vice President of the United States
Donald Trump melting down in a
completely unprecedented way which says
a lot when we're talking about Donald
Trump who has melted down on Twitter
many times before but then in the end
and again maybe something will change in
the later hours of the testimony that's
still going on as we're filming today
the first many hours have not been
particularly damaging to Trump although
there were many damaging things said or
confirmed by robert muller and Muller is
looking confused and not really with it
I have to say what I was looking for
going into the hearings today included
do Republicans go after Muller in
personally despite him having
credentials that should appeal to the
right I mean we're talking about
military a lifelong Republican a life of
public service do they try to assail his
character and they did to some degree
what new information comes out and hint
the answer is none robert muller stating
in his opening statement listen we've
charged 30 defendants we've had seven
convictions or guilty pleas but
basically the report is my statement and
i will be limiting myself to what is in
the report pointing out importantly his
report nor his investigation addressed
collusion they looked at conspiracy but
collusion is not something on which they
reached a conclusion because he didn't
look at that period and that's an
important thing but molar by and large
looking confused unable to hear
questions cut persistently I mean
regularly and I don't think it's a
strategy of trying to kill time by
asking for almost every question to be
repeated molar asking people about who
even some of the players in this thing
were at one point I believe it was David
Cicilline from Rhode Island asked about
Corey Lewandowski a very specific
question and molar said can you just
remind me who Corey Lewandowski even is
so I don't believe that this was
strategy by molar he genuinely seemed to
be having trouble hearing having trouble
recalling people's names and their role
in the investigation to some degree I
guess to be expected because you're
dealing with hundreds and even thousands
of names here but regularly saying I'm
going to pass on that one that's outside
my purview clamming up but what's in the
report is what I believe even sometimes
saying he can't comment on something
being reminded by a member of Congress
that it's in the report and then saying
oh well in that case my comment is what
is in the report I don't know that this
was particularly successful for
Democrats beyond one very specific
series of questions towards the
beginning where Muller answering with
his very short yes knows it's in the
report it's out of my purview
did confirm the obstructive nature of
Donald Trump's actions during the
investigation including that the
motivation to the extent that
the investigation came to a conclusion
on this that Trump's motivation for his
actions in attempting to obstruct were
specifically meant to interfere with the
investigation so overall will i'll go
right back to watching this after we're
done filming today and we'll have sort
of a broader analysis tomorrow of the
impact it is not seeming to me that this
testimony is going to be a game changer
and to that extent for everybody who was
waiting for something explosive to come
out of it as I said from the beginning
all we could really expect from these
hearings
well optimistically was the proactive
confirmation and publicizing of what was
already in the report Mulder made clear
the report is my statement I will not go
beyond it there were lots of damaging
things to Donald Trump confirmed but in
a way that again was sort of muddled
stumbling around in the dark seemingly
confused by Robert Muller
also we learned that Louie Gohmert
congressman Louie Gohmert is completely
off the rails and really shouldn't be a
member of Congress if you saw bits of
that testimony you'll probably know what
I mean we will have sort of a full
summary tomorrow but I don't know that
it is necessarily going to move the
needle and that is what gets me to this
next topic which is really of utmost
importance at this point in time it was
a truly wacky weekend out of the White
House a Donald Trump suffering a bizarre
and strange meltdown over a story from
The Washington Post about tweets and it
caused him to send out even crazier
tweets so on Saturday the Washington
Post wrote about Donald Trump's racist
tweets on Sunday almost like a full day
later Trump spent his morning losing his
mind over the Washington Post story and
one of the themes of that Washington
Post article which was extensively
sourced despite the tweets you're about
to see Washington Post did a really good
job 26 White House aides advisers
lawmakers and others who were involved
in handling Trump's response to the
whole go back to their original
countries Fiasco basically shared the
same perspective with the Washington
Post and the perspective was Trump
didn't and doesn't even understand why
what he said and did was controversial
and problematic like the guy just
genuine
he doesn't get it the Washington Post
story tweeted Donald Trump about my
speech in North Carolina and tweet with
it's phony sources who do not exist is
fake news the only thing people were
talking about is the record-setting
crowd and the tremendous enthusiasm far
greater than the Democrats you'll see in
2020 so the North Carolina rally he's
referring to is that rally where the
crowd chanted send her back when Donald
Trump mentioned ethnic minority
congresswoman Ilhan Omar and Trump stood
there looking quite pleased and making
no effort to interrupt it which will
play an important role later on in the
show
then on Sunday morning Donald Trump
tweeted quote presidential harassment
which is Trump's code word for a free
press reporting about what the president
does and as an integral and key part of
our system of government not an
institution that we should be attacking
that's that's what Trump means when he
says presidential harassment he doesn't
like a free press and then a couple of
minutes later Donald Trump tweeting
again quote I don't believe the for
Congress women are capable of loving our
country they should apologize to America
and Israel for the horrible hateful
things they have said they are
destroying the Democrat Party but our
weak and insecure people who can never
destroy our great nation so let's
explore this for what it is when Trump
calls something fake news that is a
statement that is of no value Trump has
said he's admitted that fake news is
news he doesn't like or news that is
critical of him so that ship has sailed
calling something fake news is of no
meaning or value whatsoever the problem
is that the meme of fake news has
metastasized we have a poll which shows
that 42% of Republicans believe that a
story that is accurate but critical of
the president is quote fake news that's
the crisis that's one of the crises the
other crisis is that once again the
constant and never-ending
misunderstandings about free speech and
censorship and most importantly in this
case press freedom are truly damaging to
our democracy free speech too
not mean freedom from the consequences
of speech I've said this before many of
you will find it
repetitive Donald Trump seems to think
that he can say outrageous racist
xenophobic things and that for it to be
free speech it has to be immune from any
consequences which includes media
writing stories about it the speech that
is people and media reacting to Trump
Trump and what Trump says is just as
important as Donald Trump's speech
itself it's arguably more important I
would actually argue because Trump has
the power and the influence of the bully
pulpit as president of the United States
it's the role of people it's the role of
voters it's the role of media to
counteract those things when necessary
or desirable lastly as usual Donald
Trump seemingly very wound up by lots of
bad things going on for him this week
that is another you know in the back of
all these things when you look at the
timing it took 24 hours for Donald Trump
to start tweeting about this Washington
Post article why well it was Sunday
going into what may not be a good week
for Donald Trump robert muller is
scheduled to testify Wednesday we will
see if that ultimately happens every
indication that it will and obviously
Donald Trump is panicking documents from
the original Jeffrey Epstein case may be
unsealed and it's likely that Trump
figures in those documents number three
the Iran Fiasco has just completely
imploded on Trump and Trump has now been
personally implicated in hush money
payments and some newly released
documents so it's not been a good week
it's shaping shaping up to be a very bad
week for Donald Trump and we have to
understand that every time these tweet
storms happen that seem to make not much
sense especially when it's been like a
full day could have been that he saw
something on Fox News that reminded him
of it don't want to you know ignore that
possibility but there is almost always a
scandal that Donald Trump is eager to
distract from and unhinged tweets to
take control of the news cycle are a
common way that he tries to do that make
sure you were following me on instagram
at david pakman I do two bribers slowly
climbing were set to
700,000 YouTube subscribers today check
that out on my Instagram and while
you're there follow the show on
instagram at david pakman show this is
really funny video of Donald Trump
stepping in it again but this time it's
much more innocuous it's not a crisis
it's just funny ignorant and lack of
context but it actually relates to a
really serious issue related to one of
the most important issues we deal with
us as a human species right now and that
is climate change and pollution and what
we're doing to our countries so let's
start with the clip and then talking
about it will be even more illuminating
after we watch make sure if you're
watching on YouTube that you've hit the
subscribe button to our Channel right
now Trump was asked about the plastic
straw controversy and here's what he had
to say I do think we have bigger
problems than plastic straws you know
it's interesting about plastic straws so
you have a little straw but what about
the plates the wrappers and everything
else in a much bigger and they're made
of the same material so the straws are
interesting everybody focuses on the
straws there's a lot of other things to
focus in but it's an interesting it's an
interesting question
you know the plates are usually not
plastic anymore so at any place that's
worried about plastic straws it's
probably paper plates but that's just
Trump being out of touch he's probably
still in the mindset of the styrofoam
food containers or something who knows
so there are like three interesting
layers here because this is just some
dumb Trump statement but there's
actually important stuff here Trump
under the belief that the straws are
plastic but so are the plates and the
cups and everything is sort of saying
like to really deal with the plastic
problem you might have to consider
banning the plates and the utensils and
the cups and everything else because the
straws are really small he seems almost
like open to the idea of banning all
plastic implements of this kind like
he's sort of saying banning only plastic
straws doesn't go far enough that's
interesting because it doesn't sound
like it would be Donald Trump's politics
now the back store
about the straws specifically is that
the reason straws have gotten so much
attention is that everyday 500 million
of these plastic straws are used once
and they're thrown away because they're
small people often don't even put them
in trash cans so that they contribute a
lot to Street trash they get into
waterways it's terrible for animals and
they're not recyclable anyway in most
cases because of their small size and
they contain such little plastic so they
wreak havoc so that part makes sense
that's why straws have become a thing
there's been a movement to replace
plastic straws either by having people
carry around their own reusable metal
straw to only give customers straws when
they've asked for them instead of
bringing them to everybody there are
some alternative straws made of like
paper and bamboo and different things
everyone i've tried is truly terrible
some coffee shops I go to have switched
to these for ice drinks and they just
fall apart into mush within 10 minutes
so it's true that while the straws
aren't a lot of plastic the things Trump
is mentioning often are paper and the
large plastic items are recyclable so he
just doesn't get why people are even
talking about straws okay
the really important message here is no
matter what we as individuals do in
terms of consumer choices like these if
we don't have big picture wholesale
change to pollution resource usage and
energy usage this stuff is a drop in the
bucket and that's why all of these
consumer movements are fine to the
extent that they'll inform people
hopefully they will impact human
behavior in some way that makes a small
change but Trump is sort of getting at
the idea that listen we're not going to
solve the crime at crisis climate crisis
that is with straws we need to be
thinking way bigger the problem is
Trump's against most of those way bigger
picture changes that need to be made
he's trying to revitalize an industry
that should be allowed to die both
because it's failing and it's terrible
for the environment the coal mining
industry just as one example from
producing benefits or trying to reduce
financial benefits on electric cars he
is completely right that if we have this
myopic focus on straws we're missing the
big a bigger picture he just doesn't
understand how
we're missing the big a bigger picture
and he's against most of the bigger
picture changes that would need to be
made if we even want to look just at
like landfills right if you just look at
solid waste landfills
it's obviously mostly not straws or even
items for eating food it's electronics
products it's wood and large industrial
plastics if we zoom out and look at the
bigger picture of solid waste beyond
just consumer we're talking about
industry and manufacturing and
construction that are generating just
untold amounts of waste way bigger than
straws we zoom out a little more and you
realize if we really want to fix this
issue we've got to look at energy usage
and then figure out where is energy
usage coming from and this dwarfs the
straw issue so my point is not laugh at
the plastic straw people or laugh at
Trump for what he said the the plastic
straw people have a specific cause it's
a logical one Trump seems to be
identifying that the straw issue is not
the be-all end-all the bring your groan
on grocery bag movement it's a good
movement but what we have to realize is
that we have to be thinking way way
bigger than these retail level consumer
choices which are important but if we
want to make real change happen and this
is why lots of corporations end up
getting behind these movements we need
to look at industry and we need to look
at transportation big picture and we
need to look at energy this is why a lot
of big corporations will say oh yeah
we're fully behind the plastic straw
thing going to paper or only bringing
straws when people ask for them they are
appearing to be part of the solution
while the real problem which is the much
broader use of energy transportation
fossil fuels that these huge
corporations contribute to that gets
ignored every time the attention gets
put on straw so Trump is right straws
are not the solution but he's against
most of the solutions that really would
make a big impact okay so before
yesterday's Robert Muller testimony I
outlined for you that Donald Trump went
on a tweet storm melting down completely
with ten tweets in a period of just a
few hours
very very clearly panicked about what
was then the upcoming testimony of
Robert Muller my prediction was at the
time Trump is not going to
to the substance and even if he does
he's not really going to understand it
because he does have significant
significantly compromised comprehension
abilities Trump is going to go by tone
Moeller was sort of slow Muller was sort
of forgetful Moeller appeared sort of
confused so Donald Trump was going to
come away thinking that he won just
Bigley because of yesterday's Robert
Muller testimony that is exactly the
case Donald Trump does believe that he
won that he came out unscathed by
yesterday's Muller testimony and we're
going to look at some of Donald Trump's
reactions now I'm not going to redo the
first segment from today's show I
already outlined for you the endless
ways in which Robert Moeller's testimony
on the facts not on the tone confirmed
that Donald Trump is absolutely
impeachable at minimum more than enough
evidence to start an impeachment inquiry
but right now I want to focus on Donald
Trump's reaction now before I get into
some of the video it is actually sad and
horrifying that our president so
severely lacks comprehension skills to
understand the substance of what Robert
Muller confirmed yesterday which is that
Trump is impeachable Trump came out
thinking it was a great day for him
let's look at some clips starting with
Donald Trump's kind of big-picture
conclusion that Muller just had nothing
to say because Donald Trump did nothing
wrong
I think Robert Muller did a horrible job
both today and with respect to the
investigation but in all fairness to
Robert Muller he had nothing to work
with you know you can be a builder but
if they don't give you the right
materials you're not going to build a
very good building Robert Muller had no
material he had nothing to work with so
obviously he did very poorly today this
might be the most disconnected one could
be from the content of the hearing
Moeller confirmed obstruction Muller
confirmed Trump directed his lawyer to
lie Muller confirmed Trump can be
indicted after leaving the White House
Muller confirmed that investigations are
ongoing Muller confirmed that as
damaging as his report was the scope was
so limited that it didn't even explore
multiple areas of wrongdoing by Donald
Trump
Moeller confirmed that Trump's actions
meet all three legal requirements to be
considered obstruction on multiple
counts Moeller confirmed that Trump was
untruthful in his written answers to
investigators now I could go on and on
but only someone who does not understand
what he saw or is lying could come away
with the conclusion that Donald Trump
purports to have come away with once
again here's another piece from earlier
in Donald Trump's
little statement where he again
summarizes everything as it was just
lovely for me so we had a very good day
today the Republican Party our country
there was no defense of what Robert
Muller was trying to defend in all
fairness to robert muller whether his
performance was a bad one or a good one
i think everybody understands that i
think everybody understands what's going
on there was no defense to this
ridiculous hoax is witch hunt that's
been going on for a long time pretty
much from the time I came down on the
escalator with our first lady
it's a disgrace what happened but I
think that they proved a lot to
everybody in fact some of my biggest
opponents wrote things today that I
wouldn't have believed they would have
written and I appreciate that they did
that this might be the height of
confusion Trump claimed since day one
that the report exonerated him and
thanked Muller for it and went on
nationwide exoneration to her events on
the basis of Muller supposedly
exonerating him which Muller didn't do
in the hearing Muller confirmed I did
not exonerate Donald Trump now Donald
Trump has shifted completely and is
saying oh yeah Muller never had the
right to exonerate me well then why did
you go on an exoneration tour on the
basis of what you believed was an
exoneration from Robert Muller which it
wasn't take a look at this so there is
no such a thing he didn't have the right
to exonerate and you know it's very
interesting people mention exoneration
that was something where he totally
folded because he never had the right to
exonerate and it was covered very well
by congressman Turner and put to a
conclusion we were if you take a look at
not only the report beyond the report
take a look at not what he said but what
he was forced to say why did you use
what you falsely believed to be an
exoneration from Muller as evidence of
your innocence if your new position is
Muller actually didn't have the right to
exonerate me at all so then attempting
to bring Donald Trump back to reality
which is tough to do some reporters
actually started pressing Trump a little
bit on hold on a second
one example Muller said you were
untruthful in your written answers and
Trump just buries his head in the sand
and says Nana booboo I wasn't untruthful
you were untruthful to the reporter and
I wish I was kidding when I said that
this is effectively what Donald Trump
did but here is Donald Trump telling the
reporter that she's the one who's lying
can you imagine anything more childish
what about what about Mother's Day
he didn't say that at all
you're on zirconia as you are untruthful
but you asked that question when you ask
that question you're on truthful you can
say molar was too reserved you can say
molar was meek you can say molar
appeared confused but molar was very
direct and clear on the issues Trump did
not tell the truth in the written
answers we already discussed that in the
first segment so first and foremost this
is a president who is completely
disconnected from reality who thinks he
came off looking great after Robert
Muller confirmed impeachable wrongdoing
by Donald Trump during the hearing but
take a step back for a second does
anyone realize how dangerous it is to
have a president whose comprehension is
so compromised that this is what he took
away from the Moller hearings let's
assume for a second that Trump isn't
lying here and he genuinely thinks the
Moller hearings were just great for him
even though Muller confirmed impeachable
behavior by Donald Trump
what is Trump taking away from
intelligence briefings if this is how
much his how significantly his
comprehension is compromised
what is Trump gleaning from meetings
with foreign leaders if he can watch
what not robert muller said yesterday
and think that he got away unscathed his
comprehension is completely compromised
and he's the President of the United
States
aside from more immediate decisions
Democrats are going to have to make
about impeach or not impeach or whatever
else this is a danger and I want to hear
from you about it I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show please follow both accounts
there okay we are about to see true what
I call c-span porn tomorrow c-span isn't
normally the place for high ratings and
exciting television but it's usually
instead a place for endless government
testimony of all kinds but tomorrow we
might actually have arguably the most
anticipated c-span type testimony before
elected officials certainly in a very
long time and by far within the trump
presidency I think a close second will
be Michael Cohen's testimony some months
ago I expect former
prosecutor Robert molars testimony
tomorrow to be extremely extremely
noteworthy and newsworthy you will
recall that Robert Muller filed a report
summarizing his investigation into
Donald Trump and in that report not only
did he say he couldn't exonerate Donald
Trump of obstruction actually clarifying
if we could have exonerated him we would
have said so he actually indicated that
on 14 possible counts of obstructive
acts by the president
all three legal requirements to be
criminal obstruction were met on eight
of those 14 possible obstructive acts
and he is going to be testifying
tomorrow and Donald Trump is truly
panicking we don't know what Muller is
going to say but even if he merely
states in clear terms what's in the
report it is going to be devastating to
Donald Trump insofar as millions of
Americans have no idea what's in the
report I've talked about this before
William bar in advance of the release of
the Moller report put out this
propaganda letter a very calculated
political document which was then used
by Trump and the people around him to go
on a national exoneration to her
claiming no collusion no obstruction and
of course then the actual report came
out doesn't match in almost any way if
when you look at the bar letter you if
you really read the Moller report you
would say the bar letter can't possibly
be a about the Muller report can it
because it bears no resemblance to the
content of the Moller report and that is
why millions of Americans who are just
busy living their lives working their
jobs earning their widely stagnant wages
and bringing their kids to school
haven't read the Moller report and so if
Muller shows up tomorrow and is just
asked about the contents of the report
and explains what's in there that alone
will be devastating to Donald Trump
never mind the fact that we might learn
about so many other things that didn't
make it into the report so Trump clearly
panicking starts tweeting yesterday that
Robert Muller simply shouldn't be
allowed to testify at all saying quote
highly conflicted Robert Moeller should
not be given another bite at the Apple
in the end it will be bad for him
and the phony Democrats in Congress who
have done nothing but waste time on this
ridiculous witch-hunt result of the
Moller report no collusion no
obstruction so there are five lies at
least that I count in this short tweet
by Donald Trump which is sort of amazing
right the economy of words with which
the president can tell so many lies
he says highly conflicted Robert Moeller
molar is a Republican and there's no
evidence of any conflict number two that
molar shouldn't be given another bite at
the Apple implying that the testimony is
a way for Muller to get Trump indicted
that's not what the testimony is lie
number three it will be bad for molar
molars in his 70s and retired I don't
think it's gonna do much for Muller
either way line number four calling this
a ridiculous witch-hunt there have been
more than a dozen indictments including
top trump staffers going to prison plus
evidence in molars report of obstruction
by the President of the United States on
eight counts doesn't sound like a witch
hunt and lie number five molar said no
collusion no obstruction of course
untrue Muller said he could not clear
Trump of obstruction and found evidence
of obstructive acts on eight of the 14
possible counts five lies in such a
short tweet but the most disturbing
thing about this is not actually the
lies in a sense we've kind of become
numb to the lies the most disturbing
thing here is Trump suggesting that
Muller shouldn't be allowed to testify
there's no legal justification for not
allowing Robert Mulder to testify
I don't believe Trump understands how
guilty and insecure he looks when he
does this even though to his followers
it doesn't really matter they fall for
the fake news witch-hunt talking points
no matter what but this is why it's
imperative that Robert Muller testify
this is why it's so important that the
content of the Moller report is
published so that clear thinking people
who again they're not avoiding the
Moller report per se they heard about
the bar letter they're busy working
they're busy raising kids they're living
their lives they simply haven't read the
Muller report and don't know what's in
it
he must testify so that more Americans
hopefully millions or tens of millions
of Americans
are exposed to the factual empirical
content of the report
Trump's only objection to molars
testimony in reality is molar testifying
has the potential to be really really
bad for me me being trumped that cannot
be allowed to silence people will be
watching tomorrow for sure I hope that
there's no funny business in the very
end in the run-up to this testimony
because it's extraordinarily important
and I look forward to seeing it and
we'll be covering it on the show the
impeachment discussions about Donald
Trump are getting both very concrete and
much less I guess abstract by by
definition the chairman of the House
Judiciary is congresswoman Jerry Nadler
Nadler is now saying that Robert molars
report contains quote very substantial
evidence that Donald Trump is quote
guilty of high crimes and misdemeanors
now you may know that there's a
particular relevance to that term high
crimes and misdemeanors are impeachable
offenses and this is sort of setting the
table for Robert molars testimony later
this week on Wednesday where Nadler says
Moeller must be allowed to spell this
out in detail in front of the committee
if there were to be impeachment hearings
it would be nag lers House Judiciary
Committee which would lead them and
there is not agreement among the
Democratic Party about whether they
should pursue impeachment at this point
there are more than 80 Democrats who
called for starting the impeachment
inquiry immediately there are some
prominent Democrats like Speaker of the
House Nancy Pelosi and Nadler himself
who have been resistant to it so the
breaking news is not Nadler thinks
there's evidence okay I want to cut
right to sort of like the core of what's
important here it's time for the
impeachment discussion to become really
specific and narrow okay because it's
not good it's not healthy it's not
productive that every time some little
thing happens oh now might be the time
for impeachment but it might not and
Pelosi says no and who knows who says
yes I've been saying for months now that
there should be an impeachment inquiry
that starts in the house
and that should start immediately or as
soon as possible that's been my position
get the contents of the molar report out
in public make everything in the report
known to as many people as possible but
Democrats need to make a decision about
this and they need to make that decision
very soon robert muller testifies
wednesday if the content of the report
justifies an impeachment inquiry which i
believe it does and remember the inquiry
is just step one in the entire process
then that inquiry should start
immediately after robert molars
testimony i happen to believe having
read the report that the contents do
justify an impeachment inquiry if it's
time to do it then let's do it
if the idea and this is a respectable
position some have the idea that it
would be more damaging to donald trump
to start the impeachment inquiry in say
six months because the 2020 election
will be more ramped up at that point in
time there would be more disruption of
trumps campaign to be done at that time
when right now it's really just the
Democratic primary that's getting
attention that's that's fine let's come
to that agreement and let's shut our
mouths about it until that point the
constant back and forth the Democrats
fighting with each other about
impeachment inquiry versus not it will
not help remove Trump in 2020 the most
effective path forward would be let
Moeller speak on wednesday publicize
what he says and allow the truth of that
testimony to foment deserved outrage in
the United States we're going to learn
much more very soon about the Jeffrey
Epstein case and it is quite possible
that Donald Trump will be implicated in
some of those documents in some way
shape or form maybe not for the alleged
child rape that Donald Trump was accused
of but possibly let's get that
information out into the open and
allowed that to grow the outrage in the
country this could easily build for the
next five to seven months and then it
could be the perfect time to start the
impeachment inquiry when it would be
most damaging to Donald Trump now some
of you will hear me talking about this
and you'll be outraged concern trolling
David are you suggesting that Dems play
politics with the timing of something as
serious as impeachment yeah I am that's
what I'm doing we need to win okay
the right plays politics with the lives
of undocumented immigrants seeking
asylum the right place politics with the
lives of civilians in Iran as Donald
Trump authorizes and then cancels a
strike on Iran they play politics with
debt and deficit in taxes and health
care I'm saying it's okay to play
politics with the timing of the
impeachment inquiry plus or minus a few
months yes that's what I'm saying
it's time to stop losing if calculating
the timing of an impeachment inquiry in
order to most damage Trump is what we
have to do it is nothing compared to
what they've done but Democrats need to
decide what the plan is like now because
the worst possible thing they can do is
just continue public infighting about it
for the next six months or 12 months or
all the way to the 2020 election that's
how Trump wins I don't want him to win
so it's time to really think about it do
we want to do it now do we want to do it
in six months or not at all and if
that's the case we focus on the 2020
election but the infightings got to stop
and the back-and-forth has to end today
let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show follow both
of us there okay I think folks are going
to like this follow up on the Gavin
McInnes situation so Gavin McInnes is
formerly one of the or he is one of the
founders of vice he hasn't been involved
with vice for a very long time he was
one of the cofounders of the proud boys
although I am told he has since
distanced himself from that extremist
group and in any case the newest thing
he's doing is he has a new show and I
was invited on to that program I told
you last week how I was offered a whole
bunch of money to be on that program
others have reported including Sam cedar
being offered $5,000 to appear on Gavin
McInnes program which is a paywall
program meaning you only can see the
content if you become a paid subscriber
my manager actually did some negotiation
with the Gavin McInnes team which may
have been actually just Gavin McInnes
communicating with my manager under a
different name and was able to actually
negotiate a pretty substantial rate and
in the midst of
this negotiation that was going on I
received a phone call from a guy named
Jim telling me that I should appear on
Gavin McInnes show who we later
determined with like 99.9% certainty was
actually Gavin McInnes himself here's a
reminder about that okay let's go next
to Howard caller from the two-five three
area code who's calling today from 2 5 3
hey David it's Jim and I just wanted to
say a longtime listener first-time
caller love ya and I just wanted to
talked about the green New Deal and just
see what ideas you had about may begin
that push through and also a guy I
despise came up on my YouTube the other
day on the commercial this is Gavin
McInnes on this new show free speech and
I was trying to click out of it right
away and then all of a sudden I saw dr.
Cornel West and Mark Lamont Hill on the
show yeah and I actually checked it out
and it's a cool show in regards to just
liberals nailing Gavin and it was so
awesome watch especially Mark Lamont
Hill I cancelled my subscription because
I saw all the shows but I just thought
it'd be awesome if you could get on his
show and destroy him for so hold your
subscription to what oh I signed up just
to watch the dr. Lamont Hill oh I see
any Cornel West show so then Sam cedar
from the majority report later did a
segment explaining that he also had been
invited to appear on Gavin McInnes
program he also talked about this call I
received from quote Jim who appears to
really have been Gavin himself Ana
Kasparian
from The Young Turks was also invited
she did a segment about it in the last
day or two and covered that as well as a
Sam and I being invited onto the program
to appear with Gavin McInnes
and now hilariously Gavin himself has
done an entire episode attacking us
because despite the offer of money we
have at least so far refused to appear
on his program which is hilarious
because
if we will only so if we get invited
with note with no money being on the
table and we refuse to appear we are not
willing to engage with the other side or
whatever if we are offered money and
appear then it's well we're only
appearing because we were given money
not because we actually want to engage
with the other side if we turn down the
appearance despite the offer of
thousands and thousands of dollars to
appear then all of a sudden the problem
is that we are just not willing to
engage with the other side even though
you would think that it would be a sign
of sort of the the the the fact that we
are not going to be tainted or
influenced by the money alone we are
going to actually make decisions about
what appearances do and don't make sense
so check this out this is a tweeted
screenshot promoting this event where
Gavin says this episode this entire
episode is dedicated to ana kasparian
sam cedar and david pakman who appear to
be outraged that gavin offered the money
to debate a conservative why is it so
hard to get liberal guests why do they
consistently refused to compete in the
marketplace of ideas and people actually
wrote to me and they said David you
really should address this like why not
just appear and compete in the
marketplace of ideas with Gavin what's
important for you to understand is that
the pitch was not debate Gavin McInnes
about this topic or that topic or the
corrosive nature of his influence on the
political discourse the invitation was
show up and have Gavin McInnes play talk
show host and moderate a discussion
between David Pakman and some
conservative Sam cedar and some
conservative ana kasparian and some
conservative and the the the problem I
have with this and I've talked to Sam
about this as well is that I feel as
though I'm contributing to the
whitewashing of Gavin McInnes in a way
that I was not immediately comfortable
with and to be clear I have not actually
turned this down the reality is I can't
go to New York City and do this until
the fall anyway I'm traveling every
single week between now and Labor Day
and we have the david pakman show summer
vacation coming up for which I'll be out
of the country so we basically just
tabled it he I guess interpreted it as
I'm turning down the appearance I'm open
in principle to appearing on Gavin
McInnes program but what I feel is the
real problem here is that number one
again by allowing him to play talk show
host and moderate a discussion between
another conservative and me I'm sort of
whitewashing McInnis and again these are
videos that would be pay wold just for
his paid audience the last thing I want
to do is give this guy paid subscribers
by allowing him to promote an appearance
that I did with someone else that
contributes to the whitewashing of Gavin
McInnes and may actually get people to
sign up and pay for his program now I'm
curious
I haven't again because the show is pay
walled I have no idea what was actually
said during this episode I'm curious
whether he addresses the fact that he
called into my show pretending to be a
guy named Jim suggesting that I should
really as a leftist go and appear on
Gavin McInnes program I don't know if
somebody has a subscription to his
program maybe they can tell me if that
comes up my guess is it does not come up